Two fundamental objects in
geometry are points and vectors.
Essentially, a point is
a location in space.
We represent a point visually as a dot.
And given a coordinate system,
we can represent it point by
its coordinates in that system.
For example, in two dimensional space,
the standard coordinate system is
the Cartesian coordinate system.
We represent a point in the system as an
ordered pair of coordinates, first the x
coordinate and then the y coordinate.
So this point located two units
to the right of the origin and
one unit below the origin
would be represented as 2, -1.
In three dimensions we can
represent a point in the similar
way as a triple of course.
First its x coordinate, then its y
coordinate, and then its z coordinate.
In contrast to a point,
a vector is an object representing
a change in position.
In Euclidean space,
a vector can be thought of as
an arrow connecting two points.
The important properties of a vector
in Euclidean space are its magnitude,
that is the length of the arrow and
its direction.
Given the coordinate system,
we can numerically represent a vector
by the amount of change it represents
in each coordinate direction.
For example,
this vector moves right by two units so
we would give it an x-coordinate of 2.
Since it moves up by four units,
we give it a y coordinate of 4.
Notice that I write a vectors
coordinate representation
differently than I do a points.
I will usually write a vector as
a column surrounded by square brackets.
While I will write a point as a list of
coordinates it surrounded by parentheses
one major difference between a point in
a vector is that a vector does not have
a fixed If I draw the same arrow
starting at a different point,
it will still be equal
to the first arrow.
This is an important distinction.
Two vectors are equal if they
represent the same amount of
change in each direction
while two points are equal,
only if they are located
in the same place.
Despite this difference,
while studying Linear Algebra,
we usually conflate the notion of a
point in a vector in the following way.
Given a coordinate system,
the point P is associated
with the vector obtained by starting at
the origin and ending at the point P.
While this is usually
a useful mental shortcut,
it is sometimes helpful to remember
the difference between the two concepts.